[Applause]
welcome back y'all you know our next
guest from a number of popular shows
she's also a very talented singer and
writer who also happens to have a new
book out it's called seasons of you and
it's out November 14th please welcome
cat Graham
[Applause]
everybody
I love your outfit I love your outfit
you look so cool did you wear this for
me cuz my name is cat I did you know
what I didn't plan that I didn't plan
that I did plan that I'm that I'm I
thought would be stalkerish no but you
just got married congratulations thank
you so
much and it was quick right you like you
decided we did a we did a private thing
we were going to do a wedding with
family and friends next year but we just
wanted to do something for us and we
woke up and and beautiful there he is
shout out to Bryant wood my love my love
I love it so I I'm going to switch gears
here just because I had no idea that
about your career like I I knew about
your career as a fan but I heard that
you like received death threats and
stuff which I found crazy it's it's a
lot of people don't know that a lot of
people that are um that are in the
industry I've received them yeah
everyone does I mean not everyone maybe
some people are are fortunate that they
don't have that even this week you know
I I get them you know sometimes
regularly but I think anytime that you
are about any sort of empowerment or
Freedom or you know um self-acceptance
and you represent any uh marginalized
Community or you're just different and
you speak up for yourself then that's
just something that kind of goes with
the territory so it doesn't bother me
because I look out and I see girls that
look like me and um people that might
have the same uh idea about human rights
that I do and I know that they might not
have the privilege to sit on your couch
and talk about it
I have to so it's it's it's it's it's
worth everything um that comes with it
for sure absolutely no I do feel there
is like a bit of responsibility with
that yeah yeah for sure I do feel that
did any of this tie in to your new book
it's it's right a seasons of you right
yeah it's right there yeah yeah yeah so
can I can I show yes you can we wanted
to like buy this like they we were like
oh sure sure but but yeah so I talk
about like the fact that we all go
through different seasons and there's so
many moments and I it looks like a
secret garden
yeah well well this actually comes off
in case you want to deal with my face
this is actually what the book looks
like I'm really happy about it and it's
um you know I designed a little uh a
keyhole so the key to your you know what
you go through but there's certain
things I talked about I talked about my
personal life I talked about um things
that I'd gone through in the industry I
talked about really everything it's the
most I'd ever talked about my my
personal Journey ever yeah uh which is
which is hard to do it's hard to do and
I'm also a bit guarded you know I I come
come across pretty um open but I do keep
a lot of things close to my chest but I
when I was approached to to write um a
book which I really thought I was just
going to be writing
um uh just a a daily to-do Journal yeah
triple Virgo was thrilled with that I
that sounds great let's just do that
let's just do that but then it winded up
becoming this which I fought the entire
way through making this book I did not
want to talk about the things that I'd
gone through or necessarily but I think
that might help people that was the
thing that made me say okay well let me
let me create something that I feel like
is going to help people so that we
understand that when there's heartbreak
and when there's loss and and when
you're having a moment where you feel
totally empowered and you have tools to
be able to navigate that when you're
feeling creative when you're when new
changes are happening when you want to
reflect when you want to reorganize like
all of these moments that happen in our
life they happen sometimes when we're
not expecting them and and and we so
often are blindsided by these moments
that you thought wouldn't happen happen
and then they happen and you don't
necessarily have the tools at your
disposal to navigate them yeah cuz I
think what's important about that too is
that I've discovered therapy over the
last few years and a lot of people can't
afford it it's expensive right so it's
kind of cool that you do something like
this because all the tools that you've
learned in life I I put in I put in
there and I'm pretty honest about about
everything and and obviously everyone
has a different way to kind of get to
your best self but this is stuff that
I've used that might be helpful for
anyone of you guys so everybody we all
want to be the better versions of
ourselves so your mother was supposed to
be a part of the book right yeah so so
again which is it was at one point I was
actually not even going to come on the
show because I was I just lost my mom
and I was like well there's an
opportunity here to to talk about her
and to honor her yeah being here and she
was originally supposed to that's my
mommy a and she was um originally
supposed to do the closing of the book
um but she unfortunately got too sick
and she she couldn't do it um and what
it what it taught me was that through
our work as
artists and through our work as people
we can continue the Legacy and and it
can be Legacy for people that are still
alive it can be your children uh or your
friends or it can be people that you've
lost um people that have passed on and
you can use whatever you've learned as
way to continue keep them alive to keep
them alive so at the end of the book now
there is a part where I kind of turn to
you guys and I ask you guys to kind of
break down what you've learned from like
your season of fall which would be like
the season that you've lost and or like
your summer the the the the your summer
that you felt super empowered and all of
those things so at the end of the book
you reflect on those things and that's
the way that you kind of continue that
on and you yeah and you yeah so you know
I I I hope I honored her and I I definit
itely talked about her her strength and
um and as much as much as I could right
yeah I did I did I hope I did good by
you Mommy I hope you're yeah oh my I
hope you're happy I hope you're happy I
don't I don't want that on I I want this
let's do another commercial break y'all
cat's book is called seasons of you it's
out November 14th but everybody here is
getting a copy you're
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home